hi my name is carrie [ __ ] and welcome to
the latest edition of mansion row on
fifth avenue
bertha russell's family newly minted by
the transcontinental railroad have
arrived and she wants everyone to know
it and so she's built this palatial
estate in the hopes that she'll attract
the curiosity of fancy new york society
these fixtures the gilded walls the
grand scale it's all designed to signal
to them that she will not be ignored
they don't know we exist well they will
now
most of the fixtures you see here were
inspired by or copied from the historic
mansions in newport rhode island this
fireplace for example is modeled after
those in the breakers
[Music]
and of course there's nothing like a
sweeping staircase to put me right in
bertha's shoes and what better showcase
is there for the beaded cape of a long
train
please come into the drawing room
the drawing room is one of my favorite
rooms on the set and not just because of
the boldini inspired portrait of bertha
on the wall portraits by buldini were
very coveted status symbols and bertha
has hers prominently displayed
most of the furniture you see in this
room are antiques that have been
reupholstered
mirroring the cone limestone of the
exterior bertha's interior also features
more limestone marble ample gold leaf
and bright colors designed to emphasize
the scale of the room these high
ceilings could swallow the most
intimidating adversary
my goodness
how splendid
the columns you see here in the dining
room were also fashioned after those in
the breakers
this tablecloth was fabricated by
seamstress in russia and based off of
our team's research
every detail on the set was meticulously
researched and sourced by regina graves
and her team this red damask for example
was reprinted by the original
manufacturer from an old file
and like her historical counterpart alva
vanderbilt the bertha would have been
involved at every level of decision
making we finished the gilding in the
ballroom
no you think you finished the gilding mr
kowalski but nothing is finished till i
decide
our production designer bob shaw says
that bertha's bedroom is a tribute to
alba vanderbilt's bedroom at the marble
house in newport it's filled with
antique trinkets historical
reproductions if someone were to wander
in from the brookhouse they might ask
where's the sink betraying once again
the russell's extravagant wealth whereas
the brookhouse would have had sinks in
the bedroom and a shared common toilet
the russells have their toilet and
bathtub in one modern bathroom i know
it's shocking hallelujah let the
trumpets sound thank you for joining me
on this tour of bertha's extraordinary
home
[Music]
you